hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the walking dead season 7
episode 8 the midseason finale hearts
still beating and after half a season of
negan murdering Glenn and Abraham
kidnapping Daryl threatening Carl's
stealing all their guns and making Rick
thank him for all of it Rick decides
that negan has finally gone too far and
needs to be dealt with because he killed
the woman in charge of food and the
mama's boy who tried to betray him ok
that's it we're going to war war girl
but I was actually really happy with how
these last two episodes ended up and the
direction that the series is going so
there's a lot to talk about stuff that
you might have missed a few questions
that you might have and I'm gonna get
into all of it so let's get started with
these opening images so we open on
Maggie at the graves of Glenn and
Abraham at the hilltop and we've gone
several weeks of trying to move on from
Glenn and Abraham's deaths but this
episode specifically wants to bring us
back to that moment so everything about
Maggie here is designed to evoke Glenn
she actually kind of looks like Glenn
wearing the hat like that
I think that's intentional and the early
days of the series before meeting Maggie
Glenn wore this hat everywhere and it
wasn't until Maggie took off the hat
that he stopped wearing it so clearly
Maggie is honoring her late husband here
also Maggie climbs to this lookout post
and gazes out into the distance exactly
like she did last season in Alexandria
remember when Glenn was resurrecting
under a dumpster it's almost as if part
of Maggie is hoping that Glenn will come
back to her and it's kind of a sweet
moment and I'll talk more about it later
now notice this moment when Maggie takes
Gregory's Apple one cool thing that
struck me about this episode was the way
it uses food pretty much every storyline
features food in some way and I'm not
just talking about the usual Walker food
of human beings but I'm talking pie
spaghetti peanut butter pomegranate
seeds what does this smorgasbord mean
well in this episode food is used to
symbolize power and control so when
characters take or steal food they're
seizing control from someone else but
when food is willingly offered
characters are trying to sneakily
control others by putting them in their
debt basically that old adage of there's
no such thing as a free lunch and this
keeps coming up a lot so I'll come back
to it but in this moment Gregory doesn't
want to give Maggie the Apple she forces
it away from him with this other hilltop
her scolding Gregory for withholding
food from a pregnant woman Maggie
demonstrates that the Hilltoppers are on
her side taking the Apple and Gregory's
power I eat
your Apple and then later Maggi double
downs on this control gobbling down even
more of Gregory's apples in this apple
pie that the hilltoppers made for her so
this isn't just the typical food
cravings of a pregnant woman she's
further extending her control over the
hilltop now this episode jumps around a
lot before all the [ __ ] goes down in
Alexandria so I'm just gonna go
storyline by storyline and break down
each character's art so let's start with
negan shaving in Rick's bathroom with
Jeffrey Dean Morgan finally getting that
clean-shaven look that negan has in the
comics remember in the last breakdown I
talked about how negan was trying to
play mind games by replacing Rick in his
family unit corrupting that sense of
domesticity and now we see him
continuing that shaving his beard
exactly like how Rick's shaved his beard
back in season 5 both of these moments a
new sheriff had come to town resulting
in both sheriff's going on a power trip
and getting those clean-shaven faces
covered in stuff holes blood he also
gives Carl this advice Franken now I've
never shaved myself I've had this gruff
since I was a baby but when you shave
you can either shave with the grain in
the direction that your hair grows to
avoid bombs but if you want a closer
shave you really should shave against
the grain even though that might cause
some irritation and I think negan saying
this could be a metaphor of his unique
leadership style
he doesn't mind people who go against
the grain people who break the rules and
irritate him as long as it shows guts
and courage to him that results in a
smoother relationship what he hates is
when people try too hard to placate him
and please him
these sycophants who tried to take the
easy way out going with the grain negan
prefers a little fight and then of
course we get another example of food
representing control with negan offering
Carl a taste of his spaghetti sauce this
whole meal is just a manipulative mind
game by negan Carl Olivia and Judith
aren't dinner guests they're really
terrified captives okay now let's move
on to Rick and Erin as they paddle out
to that boat I like how Erin uses the
plank from the sign we saw in last
episode and if you look closely the
words on each of their paddles are I am
dead Burak and have at it [ __ ] for
Erin and each of these phrases reflect
their mental states at the top of this
episode so Rick is still affected by
Michonne's words
episode four he's wondering what kind of
life this is and he feels like a hollow
dead person under negan's oppressive
rule but Aaron feels the opposite that
as long as he's still alive things are
still worth fighting for even if it
means he has to scavenge for stuff and
say to the Savior's okay have at it
[ __ ] and that is why as they load up
the truck later Aaron says the words
that inspire the episodes title hearts
still beating but either your hearts
beating or it isn't your loved ones
hearts are beating or they aren't we
take what they give us so that we can
live and Aaron repeats this later on
after the Savior's jump him for pretty
much no reason
Aaron is helping Rick understand that
their lives don't have to be over before
I move on a few things that I really
need to point out about the storyline
first a lot of people were saying that
that floating Walker with the beard is
Walking Dead comic creator Robert
Kirkman and even though he kind of looks
like him another angle from the behind
the scenes clip shows that that is
clearly not Robert Kirkman but really
this storyline also leaves us with some
of the biggest mysteries of this episode
what is the meaning of the note saying
congrats on winning but you still lose
why is there no ammo in these guns and
most importantly who is this mystery
person in Boots stalking Rick and Aaron
who we see at the end of this scene and
later spying on Alexandria in the
post-credits scene okay so I have a few
theories on this one is that this is all
an elaborate obstacle course trap laid
by that crazy survivalist guy from the
sign Leslie Williams starting like
notice how he left a rowboat fold with
bullet holes that would last you just
long enough to make it to a canoe with
floating Walker traps that you have to
navigate through with the reward of tons
of guns with no ammo that all seems
weirdly laid out and intentional and the
thought is that this mystery man would
want to lure in scavengers who are just
desperate enough for guns so he could
follow them back to their homes which
would make some fanatic sense because we
would see that in Rick's case again
there is no such thing as a free lunch
but then another theory is that whoever
left this stuff is just dead and
whoever's watching them is just someone
else unrelated to the boat so for
example Cindy from Oceanside the person
in the post-credits scene has hands that
a lot of people are saying look like
they belong to a woman but Cindy wasn't
wearing those boots in episode 6 and
both these scenes I think really want
these boots to be
and iconic another theory that I'm kind
of leaning towards is that this could be
a survivor of Meegan's Massacre of all
the men from Oceanside this guy might
have escaped with like a ton of guns and
became like a hermit on this houseboat
other people are saying that this
character could belong to another group
from the comics called the whisperers
which I don't want to say too much about
yet but I don't think this is them
because there are just so many things
that happen in the comics between now
and when the whispers show up and the
whispers are really cool characters and
this wouldn't be the most exciting way
to introduce them on the show so just
trust me on this anyway whoever this is
I'm betting it's a new character because
there's nothing in the comics anything
like this storyline and it might be
possible that this person is just
keeping a ton of ammo in a separate
location and he or she is going to end
up being kind of an ace in the hole for
Rick maybe arming him in his coming war
with the Savior's or linking him with
Oceanside which also has a ton of guns
and would be doing the same thing or I
don't know maybe it's Beth hashtag Beth
lives
hashtag Beth and boots but let's move on
to Carol and Morgan's storyline so that
idea of food representing control is all
over the place in the scene starting
with this close up of pomegranate seeds
remember in my breakdown of episode two
I talked about how King Ezekiel used
pomegranates to try to seduce Carol into
stayin in his kingdom but now this fruit
along with other food Ezekiel and
Richard abroad and the fruit Morgan
brings er is all another example of
characters using offerings of food to
try to control people and of course
Carol refuses because she doesn't want
to be controlled she wants to be on her
own and then later on in the storyline
Carolyn Morgan refused Richard begging
them to convince Ezekiel to attack the
Savior's Carol wanting to stay out of
the conflict and Morgan worried about
future loss of life now Carolyn Morgan's
still both believe what Rick Spencer
Gregory Ezekiel and others believe that
a lasting peaceful arrangement can be
made with the Savior's that will prevent
people from dying but remember Carol and
Morgan still have no idea that Glenn and
Abraham are dead so as Maggie Sasha
Rosita Daryl Michonne and Richard here
know full well and it's Rick's about to
find out peace with the Savior's just
isn't possible they're just too sadistic
and erratic they kill innocent non
participants without warning and you
can't build trust with people like that
so what
see if Carolyn Morgan's opinions change
when they catch up on current events and
before I move on we get a quick scene
later with Richard in a secret trailer
in the woods crying over non-existent
milk seriously what the hell is going on
here Richard did mention that he lost
people they lost people and my theory is
that this is a place that he used to
live in before joining the kingdom and
he's checking back on it just in case
his people that he lost maybe a family
member have returned now I don't think
he's the Phantom of the boots but if you
give us about this guy let me know what
you think his deal is okay moving on to
Darryl's storyline so after using the
key and the go now note that slipped to
him last episode he hides in this room
and devours peanut butter again taking
food means a character is seizing
control and for the first time in a
while daryl is fully in charge of his
own fate and in case you didn't catch
this Daryl looking at these card
figurines signals to him that this is
Dwight's room because remember we saw
Dwight carving these at the beginning of
episode three and Dwight actually gave
Darryl one of these figurines last
season to trade for Tina's insulin and
speaking of Dwight this episode really
didn't underline this but I think we
have an answer to who slipped Darryl
that key now last episode I was leaning
towards Jesus but also speculated that
could have been Sherri but now I'm
pretty sure that it was Dwight because
Dwight took Darryl's motorcycle in
episode 4 and now Darryl has the key to
it which I'm assuming was the same key
on that note and that Dwight was the one
who gave it to him now we know Dwight
freakin hates negan and on some level he
might respect Daryl for standing up to
him enough to help him escape maybe
he'll know we'll see now I know a lot of
people were shocked by Daryl murdering
fat Joey after he surrendered but Daryl
definitely has his reasons remember in
that season 6 episode with Dwight and
Cherie Savior's have fed Daryl empty
promises before totally screwing him
over and I'm sure Daryl hasn't forgiven
and forgotten fat Joey for beating the
crap out of oh man episode 3 but Daryl
cements his reasons with this line hey
just [ __ ]
so getting it all so that Joey was
reasoning that there's a commonality
between them that they're both just
following orders and doing what it takes
to get by and survive but Daryl sees
this is more of an us-versus-them deal
so just like Rosita and Michonne in the
others Daryl knows that war is
inevitable and there's no sense in
trying to see your common humanity with
the other side and speaking of Michonne
let's talk about her storyline here so
she spends most of this episode with
this savior Isabel on a road trip to
negan and in her first scene Michonne
says that her goal is to find a weakness
in the Savior's just for herself she
Chavez ends for me in other words she's
in this alone but then in the later
scene Michonne looks down at this
massive Savior camp and she realizes how
outnumbered her people are and that she
can't do this alone and I'll come back
with that idea but a lot of people were
wondering whether Michonne actually
killed the Savior and if you look
closely in this wide shot you definitely
make out a gunshot going off in the car
as Isabel's frame slumps down also
anyone else find it weird for Michonne
to just quickly hop behind the wheel
with a dead body still in seat Michonne
you know you can like pop open the door
and shove that body out first okay
moving on to Rosita who we first see
with the bullet Eugene made for her
waiting for her moment to shoot negan
notice what Rosita says when Gabriel
asks her why it has to be her to go on
the suicide mission if Abraham was alive
we could fight if Glenn was Maggie's kid
would have a father Michonne and Carl
can fight they have Rick Aaron has Eric
Eugene knows things Daryl's strong and
of course she left out Donatello who
does machines and Rosita is implying
that she has no important function to
the group and it would have been better
if negan clobbered her instead but also
this is a callback to her line to
Spencer early last season this group
favored him in this place make sure you
got something worth dying for
Rosita now feels a bit lost that without
Abraham she has no one to die for and
thus no one to live for and then Gabriel
telling her that they need her might be
why Rosita seems to have a bit of a
change of heart when she talks to
Spencer short while later now it's easy
to forget that these two were a thing
for a little while and Rosita doesn't
want to feel like she's drifting alone
anymore
wants to have someone to die for and
Spencer revealing to her that he
actually has a long-term plan to strike
negan further down the road reopens the
door to actually having some kind of
future with Spencer a future that of
course will never happen because let's
talk about Spencer this episode from the
very beginning we can see Spencer trying
to play the game with the Savior's
shaking their hands flirting back with
this savior woman who flirts with him
and notice again maybe I'll buy you
sandwich which is another example of
someone offering food as a way to
control them and after we see Spencer
working up the guts to talk to negan
changing into this new sharp outfit a
gray shirt with khakis huh great choice
he makes this same move back with negan
trying to get in his good graces by
offering him nourishment in the form of
booze and from the moment Spencer sits
down with negan anyone who read the
comics or picked up on my dumb jokes all
season long knew where this was going
Spencer tries to buddy up with negan
asking him to replace Rick with himself
and negan spills his guts everywhere and
just like with the season premiere the
show found a way to make this scene in
the comics even more disgusting in the
comics negan swung the knife to slash
through Spencer stomach but here he
stabs him from close range and the guts
spill out like pinata candy barf that is
almost as gross @ oh god I was going to
set it up I was going to set it up and
as we saw last episode some of the best
dialog here is just taken directly from
the comment he is swallowing his hate
and getting [ __ ] done that takes guts
you got no guts there they are
you were inside you all time you did
have God I've never been so wrong in my
whole life but there are two key
differences one negan and Spencer aren't
playing pool yet in the comics they're
just on their way - and - in the comics
it's Carl who shoots Lucille and a
shootout that happens a little while
later not Rosita
so when Lucille gets hit negan snaps and
we've never seen him this truly angry
before but notice how quickly he
collects himself focusing instead on the
real matter at hand someone made this
bullet a nigga's ability to control his
emotion like this is another example of
his psychopathic tendencies if someone
tried to shoot Rick or anyone else on
the show they would have put down the
shooter a media
no questions asked but negan psycho
enough to restrain himself because
freaking out isn't really negan style
this is Nagin style kill show motor ah
damn it
alright P Olivia we knew ye just enough
to care about ye when he died my big
question here is why does negan kill
Spencer and Olivia but not kill Rosita
or Karl for that matter so negan killing
Spencer connects back to that against
the grain idea negan admires Carl and
Rosita for surprising him with how much
guts they have trying to kill him Rosita
even doubles down with that courage
leaning into a rocks blade showing negan
that she's ready to die and negan is
impressed he doesn't want to kill
someone like that he considers it more
fun and more productive to break them
meanwhile negan viewed Spencers attempt
to kiss his ass and get him to kill Rick
for him as a sneaky act of cowardice and
that disgusts negan and Spencer paid the
price for it and then with Olivia
negan's logic was the same for killing
Glenn remember Glenn didn't attack negan
Daryl did but he killed Glenn to
paralyze the group with intimidation so
when one person acts out another random
person will get punished it's like
Russian Roulette anyone can go at any
time and it keeps everyone from turning
on him at once or turning a lone
assassin into a martyr it screwed up but
it's effective and it's that same
practical thinking that leads negan to
taking Eugene with him instead of
killing him like Daryl he sees something
useful in a guy that can make bullets so
just like the massacre that opened this
season Rick is left without a critical
piece of his offense okay moving on to
this scene in the jail cell where
Michonne inspires Rick with this moving
speech about how she realized that they
can't take down the Savior's alone which
echoed the conversation between Enid and
Sasha earlier but why did the scene
begin with Rick staring at his axe and
this note that he found on the houseboat
so on a literal level
Rick's axe is his only weapon right now
which is useless against an army of
armed saviors and this note reminds him
that despite scoring all those guns on
the houseboat he still lost them at the
end of the day but these two objects
also work on a metaphorical level so
without his gun Rick still doesn't feel
like his whole sheriff self and the note
reminds him that no matter
how many victories he gets they're all
still losses under negan and that a life
under negan's rule isn't worth living if
he keeps ending their lives at any
random moment therefore rick has to
fight and that brings us to our closing
images this extended montage that
mirrors both the opening scene of this
episode and the opening episode of this
season Maggie again mourns Glen and
Abraham looking out past the hilltop
walls and hopes of Glen coming back to
her and in a way he kind of does because
for the first time since the season
premiere the gang is back together
including Daryl and Jesus and Glen and
Abraham - well they're corpses all
united under one common purpose to
avenge the deaths of Glen and Abraham
and sure Denise Spencer and Olivia - by
gearing up for war and then Daryl
returns Rick's Colt Python restoring the
authority that he's been missing all
this time and these shots of everyone's
faces is a callback to the negan lineup
that started the season except now it's
inverted the faces of fear have
transformed in two phases of hope and as
they march to the house hopefully to
toss Gregory out of window or something
they have never looked more alive this
season because their hearts are still
beating now before I get to some
lingering questions I wanted to give a
quick look at the promo footage from the
second half of the season
which returns in February so in a
clipper episode 9 we see Jesus telling
Rick about the kingdom it gets time I
introduced you to Ezekiel King is he
cute and the other footage that we've
seen shows Rick making a pitch to
Ezekiel in the auditorium of the kingdom
two night their forces along with some
going down between Richard and that dick
Savior Jared from episode 2 so I
predicted episode 9 the first shots of
this war against the Savior's will be
fired and since Rick and the rest will
be at the kingdom I think we're going to
see how Carol and Morgan react to the
bad news of everyone's deaths they're
gonna be like oh no not Spencer and
Bolivia we also get this mysterious shot
of a porcupine Walker sneaking up behind
Rick with a bunch of spikes poking out
of them now this looks awesome
in the comics some characters do use
Walker's and creative ways but I don't
remember seeing this exactly so if the
show does go in this direction I'm
really excited to see what kind of
weaponized Walker's they assemble for
this oncoming war like maybe they'll
build like a catapult made of Walker
arms and legs I don't know guys the
possibilities are endless okay a few
Linc
one who is the mysterious person in
Boots do you think they're connected to
the houseboat or was this just like a
random passerby and do you think this is
someone that we already know or a brand
new character - do you think Dwight
helped Derral escape and if so does this
make Dwight a good person I feel like
every time negan hits on Shari we get
this sad reaction shot of Dwight looking
miserable and I think the show really
wants us to feel sympathy of this guy I
mean come on that guy got a bite to the
dick how could he not feel sympathy for
him and then finally did Spencer deserve
to die now his death means the official
end of the Munro family and even though
I think the show wanted us to kind of
hate Spencer at times I also feel kind
of bad that his thoughtful approach to
problem solving and compromise which she
inherited from Deanna's experience as a
congresswoman is now absent from this
world with no one left to carry that
torch now I know this is a Walking Dead
and this is a rotator strip and it's us
or them but I also think the show works
best when Rick's leadership methods are
tested okay thanks for watching and let
me know what you think in the comments
it's been really great breaking down the
walking dead over this half season so
check out my breakdowns of all the other
episodes and keep an eye out for future
Walking Dead videos on this channel and
of course please hit like and subscribe
to new rockstars and share this video
with all your friends you can also
contribute to us on patreon thanks so
much to all of our current donors
especially Kevin chaw Han go ahead and
for the rest of you if you aren't
currently a patron we would love your
support you can hit me up on twitter at
EI vos with any thoughts on The Walking
Dead or you can follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates and
winner videos are coming out alright
thanks for watching bye
[Music]